good afternoon my name is Matt O'Connor
I'm a product manager from Google's
cloud platform and this is aaron philip
he joins us from one of our partners
Christ Waterhouse Coopers and we're
gonna talk a little about some cloud
security today and we really appreciate
you guys sticking it out because we
realize we're the last stop for
cocktails so hopefully we'll make this
interesting for you all Niels this
morning spoke a lot of it gave you guys
a good overview how we think you know
what we've done to secure Google and to
secure the cloud what I was going to
talk about a little bit here today is
going to talk about our perspective on
security from a Google point of view to
hopefully seed some thoughts with with
you all as you as you look to taking
advantage of the cloud and be able to
take advantage of some of the way we
think about things first of all we live
in kind of a rough world and so one of
the things that one of the things that
we are constantly doing is we're
constantly doing a risk analysis of
things that we do and we were we're
assessing our environment to help us
make informed decisions what I'm showing
you here is this is an example of what
the kind of the network weather looked
like back in May this is called the
digital attack map you can go find this
online and look at it and you can see
the kind of the weather for today but
this is showing DDoS attacks and stuff
and we get a lot of this kind of traffic
on our network and so we've we've built
capabilities to protect a lot of our
services some of our cloud products take
advantage of that for example if you're
using our a pinch and product you're
shielded from these these kinds of
attacks but I'm just kind of trying to
give you a sense of the global
environment that we live in we also
think about you know that there's kind
of this traditional security model where
you know we're hard on the outside soft
on the inside and so one of the
assumptions that we're making from a
Google point of view is that the network
is compromised
and that the threat is close to us and
so we're constantly working on defense
in depth and doing smart kinds of things
to minimize our risk but also simplify
you know simplify the way we do things
to help us mitigate that risk a little
bit more on the threat assessment you
know so I showed you the map I showed
you the attacks on what's going on and
these are the kinds of things that we're
paying attention to is to put more into
that risk model who's who are our
attackers what kinds of things are they
looking for what are the high-value
things that we want to protect and use
that to inform our decisions but the
other thing you know the other thing
that we have is because we do this on a
very large scale we capture a lot of
data and we use that data to help us
make these decisions and I'm going to
come back to that in a minute because I
that's an important point here in a
second Neil's talked about the eight
layers of the stack this morning and I
thought that was a fabulous presentation
let me talk to you a little bit about
some other kind of intangible pieces of
that but one of the I wish I wouldn't
say necessarily intangible but one of
the things that that we've done and we
continue to do is we foster a very
strong security culture and we make
security everybody's responsibility we
train people in security we partner up
with each other when we see common
problems will address those and educate
our educate our employees to be vigilant
for these kinds of things and avoid
stuff and through doing all of these
kinds of activities it helps us it helps
us in simplifying the problem because we
have many hands on the problem when
we've got people thinking about it and
we've got people collaborating with each
other to reduce these risks and simplify
the problems part of that culture is
also giving back to the environment that
we live
and so what I'm showing you here is just
several of the innovations that we've
come up with over time that we've shared
with the broader community and we hope
that you take advantage of and you know
for example you know two-factor
authentication is a big thing that we're
really is really important to us before
we use that as on all of our employees
and it's it's just the way we do
business and it becomes part of that
culture and it becomes a regular thing
and it doesn't become difficult for your
employees to do to help protect your
assets Neil's and Joe talked about all
the infrastructure that we built and
everything I won't spend a lot of time
on that but and then the other piece of
it is is that we're very operationally
vigilant and we because we have this
global network which I can show you in
my next slide we have this point of
presence I showed you the the threat map
and what what's happening in our
environment and we have this this global
network and we're in over 33 we're just
basically around the globe which enables
us to deliver applications at you know
with very high performance to users all
over the planet but also our customers
of cloud platform get to take advantage
of this network but because its networks
everywhere we we gather a lot of data
and the the point that I'm trying to
make is is that we use that to make Dan
informed decisions and so what I'm about
to do is I'm going to hand things over
to Aaron and he's going to talk to you
about a tool that his team is built that
uses a lot of data to help wrangle the
security problem awesome so thanks Matt
again just by way of introduction my
name jaron Phillip the head architect on
our solutions that we're doing under the
banner of something called reinvent
security together in our Google Alliance
and just to talk just for two seconds
about what really how this comes
together in practice if you look at pwc
you know we have
massive amount of business knowledge how
organizations run globally how they
manage risk how they address change you
look at Google what they have from a
technology standpoint being able to take
those two things put them together is
something that that we've you know as
we've gone out to our clients and as
we've gone out to the market both from
where their needs sit and then also what
we've been able to do to help them has
been enormously impactful what I'm going
to talk about today and this is kind of
a subset of our security portfolio that
we're working on together with Google is
is what we generally call PWC security
analytics powered by Google and there's
two main components to this one is the
actual security analytics itself and the
other is something we call the threat
intelligence fusion center which allows
us to take threat intelligence from
points all over the place worldwide fuse
it together actually understand what it
means what the risks are and then map
that into the organization right we've
actually in this is generally when I
want to talk about this people are
surprised by this but we've actually
been doing this type of work for years
for some very very large clients we
built out really our first cyber
analytics platform in 2012 and I'll give
you a little background on why we had to
do this right we were working a major
investigation at that point where we had
something on the order of 500 servers
were compromised we had about 550
billion artifacts that we had to get
through many many many terabytes of data
which at that point in time was was you
know a fairly large scale set of data
when we had about three to four weeks to
complete the entire investigation right
and I'm not sure how many of you are
familiar with kind of traditional
forensic techniques than those types of
things but they simply were not going to
cut it and so we went and we looked and
we said all right how can we actually
accelerate all this and we built out our
first platform figured out how to pull
in data programmatically how to actually
look at all those images at once how to
map that from a normalization standpoint
into the 550 billion artifacts we had on
top of it and how to actually and this
is really was most importantly for
client how to map what was happening in
the business on top of that technical
data and we did all of that in one of
our labs in DC with about a 30 to 40
node Hadoop cluster right so being able
to take data that would have taken us
days to search using kind of traditional
methods cut that down to something that
we could run through the dupe in about
four hours we thought we were all now
data scientists and it was going to be
amazing right but let me tell you a
little bit about what happened at that
point we ran our first search and the
first search ran on about 250 terabytes
of data and the result set was five
terabytes right and we realized very
quickly we had to get much much better
from an analytic standpoint because how
we were doing and we were
state-of-the-art and at that point in
time as far as how to do forensic
analysis what but what we were doing
simply did not work because the day the
data that was was going in was too big
and the data that we still had to call
through after the analytics was way too
big and so we had a really redesign and
look at how do we layer in other things
that are non-traditional whether it be
you know information about the business
unstructured data that's very difficult
to work with how do we start hooking
this stuff in right and we really
started about a four-year journey of a
lot of lessons around just that how do
we take in a PDF that comes from the US
government that has a series of
technical indicators that we need to go
look for and immediately operationalize
that right and how do you make sure that
somebody doesn't inadvertently type in a
keystroke wrong and then all of a sudden
you're firing up all kinds of false
positives you didn't know about being
able to solve these problems at small
scale is kind of an interesting problem
but being able to solve it at the scale
you know our clients demand from us on a
single engagement and then what we do
globally at that scale is a whole
different ball game
and so we built this stuff out
internally and we started our alliance
with Google we first kind of approached
them and said hey we've got these kind
of interesting security tools we're
using internally this could be a really
interesting you know alliance where we
come together use your platform take
what we know about how to actually do
these types of analytics how to layer in
the business risk and and do it at real
scale all right and that's what we did
and so I just gave the example of being
able to take a query from days 24 hours
and a Hadoop infrastructure you know we
now have that running essentially
interactively in a matter of seconds
using things like Google's bigquery
right and that's really irregardless of
scale I'll talk a little bit more about
this when you start talking about some
of the the real world stuff we deal with
but just give you an idea of what what I
consider scale and what we consider
scale we have a client that's coming up
that has a requirement for 50 petabytes
of data 50 petabytes of data right the
proof of concept we're doing with them
will encompass about 10 to 15 petabytes
worth of data that's what we consider to
be I will call that moderately large
scale right there's stuff above it but
we have to be able to address that need
because that's you know that's what our
clients are asking from us so i have i
have had the the good fortune of being
able to really kind of go around the
world over the past 12 18 months and
talk to really some of the you know
strongest companies and strongest public
sector organizations worldwide and this
is what has come out of these
conversations right when we talk to
these guys and it's really interesting
because irregardless of sector
irregardless of where they're located
these are the these are the general
themes that come out number one data
volume massively increasing right this
is lead because of the problem i was
mentioning before about em precise
analytics creating a whole bunch of
alerts whole bunch of false positives
this has led to a massive backup in the
people monitoring these alerts right
you know there's if you look at any
major breach the company will absolutely
get ripped apart because someone will
invariably find an alert in their
security systems that would have
notified them about that breach that was
unaddressed but let's be fair that
organization for half a second right it
is not uncommon for a large-scale
organization today to be taking in ten
to fifteen thousand alerts per day being
able to a hole that down from ten to
fifteen thousand alerts down to the five
that really matter is a massive massive
issue for companies for companies
worldwide right the other problem
they're having is because of the large
data scale and what they're having to do
on the infrastructure side to build out
storage you know maintain all the
regulatory requirements actually be able
to look at the data they are having to
make artificial decisions about what
they look at and what they don't look at
right and they're making these decisions
not on the value of the data necessarily
but they're making it based on the size
of the data and so what happens is and
we see this over and over and over it
again are in our incident response
practice where we go in what we call
kind of write a boom after something
terrible's happen is they don't have the
data necessary to actually complete the
full picture and the reason they don't
have that data is because they had to
make this kind of artificial choice
about what they want to keep and what
they wanted to give away right and
that's and that really goes down to this
concept of limited budget and sufficient
processing power wealth of data not
being used and then the last thing I'll
talk about is the inability to extract
value out of the data and this is
something you know we've seen on the
private sector side and it's also
something we've seen in the public
sector side we're being able to tell
good data from bad and actually linking
the data together correctly and showing
how it joins so you may have something
that seems worthless as this point up
here but being able to only get with
vulnerabilities be able to link it with
threat intelligence be able to only get
with what's happening in the business
and actually do all that at scale and
atpase is a very very hard problem all
right so this is when we looked at what
we wanted to address with this solution
this is really where it were had
rap and so we came up with these four
kind of foundational requirements right
one we call automation of detection and
I'll explain what that means in a second
to superior intelligence being able to
take in threat intelligence from all
over the place and make best use of it
at scale absolutely critical visibility
of everything not just focusing on the
technical data but actually
understanding what it means the business
and the organization as those alerts
come in as are prioritized and as
they're dealt with right and then lastly
real-time analysis if you're not able to
do 12 and 3 at scale in real time you
know there's not a whole lot of value in
one two and three right you can do some
of this stuff in batch but being able to
do this in real time and catch this
stuff especially well as stuff moves
into kind of these newer infrastructures
where you can actually automate
responses in the infrastructure is going
to be absolutely vital right so let's
talk about one and two just for half
second year automation in tection what
do we mean when we talk about this right
historically security analytics writ
large has been about pattern matching
signature analysis kind of first level
first order analysis some of the more
advanced stuff that's coming out maybe
certain types of clustering and those
types of things around basic accounting
right it's really interesting when you
see kind of what in these really
advanced clients what works and what
doesn't I can kind of break into two
buckets from what we've seen things like
anomaly detection machine learning those
are what i would call kind of near near
time predictive right so maybe they can
predict to an hour maybe they can
bricked two minutes they're not going to
give you a week warning or two weeks
warning or three weeks warning that
something's happening generally they are
out there there to find the unknown
unknowns that are already occurring in
the network right and there's a massive
amount of research going into how to do
that better and the great news for us is
having a you know partner like Google
being able to take what they're doing
the machine learning side leverage that
into
types of business problems is actually
really really interesting and I'll talk
about that in a second but when you talk
about long-term actually getting ahead
of the threat threat intelligence by far
is where that sits today right and this
is understanding when a sophisticated
threat group has started up a new
campaign and understanding that they're
hitting some other region in the world
and we know from past experience that
they start there to test all their tools
and once they're comfortable thing they
will then move to the US right or
whatever region you happen to be in
having that kind of visibility and that
kind of view and actually being able to
operationalize that is absolutely
critical for organizations going forward
so we want we look at these you know
number one and number two is kind of
this near-term and longer term thing the
other side of this is you know going
back to the machine learning concepts
being able to take in some of the things
like the the image recognition and image
classifier stuff actually can can marry
into visibility of everything right so
being able to take unstructured data
that are screenshots or you know
desktops those types of things and being
able to pick up when a terminal window
has been opened just by using kind of
image recognition is something that's
very very interesting right because
there may be some off you skatin anti
forensics they're doing on the back end
to not pick up when cmd.exe gets run but
we can pick that up actually on the
front end using using image recognition
and I've talked talked around this but I
want to hit a couple points and this is
you know when we talk about this with
our clients being able to kind of dip
into this you know for lack of a better
term you know massive pool of resources
whether it be compute whether it be
storage you know I remember when I made
the phone call about the the 50 petabyte
thing saying hey is this going to be a
problem for you guys the answer was no
and it was not just know is like tell us
when you want to start because we can go
ahead and just ramp this up like
tomorrow if you need to write so being
able to do that that kind of activity
and being able to throw you know 30 40
nodes if you need to at just a parsing
engine because you have some really
complicated etl you're trying to do and
have that still be cost effective is an
enormous is an absolutely massive
differentiator when you look at how
these these you know how things are done
today and security versus how they can
be done in the future so having said
that I want to dive a little bit into
what we're actually doing on the threat
intelligence side right we do a lot it's
interesting you know people think of us
as kind of an accounting firm some of us
knows we have consulting we're actually
one of the largest if not the largest
information security practice in the
world in the consultants own right and
we have off we have offices in thing we
have 157 countries give or take don't
don't quote me on that exact number we
have hooks cross region and around the
world and being able to take data from
all those different client bases and
understand what that means and map that
into some of the other collection
activities we do is very interesting
right so we're actually tracking around
110 different distinct threat actors
this generates a ton of data right so
just to talk through what this actually
means from a what do you do with it once
you once you collect it you know our
threat intelligence fusion center
platform we talked about what we use
internally has something in the order of
I think it's you know 200 million give
or take documents in it right from all
over the place
we've mapped that into a very very large
graph and being able to do threat
analytics on that in real time as data
comes in from all these different parts
of the world absolutely absolutely
critical right and when we help our
clients out with how they solve these
problems we're finding more and more and
more they start they start collecting
threat intelligence they you know maybe
they have some public private
partnership maybe they have some feed
they're paying for and they realized
very quickly they have a problem because
they have no way one they have no way to
operationalize it's actually get it into
their environment to check what's
happening and then to even if they did
have that way to operationalize it they
have no way to rank order right and so
what will invariably happen is we'll
find out from them that somehow IP
addresses of a CDN or some other kind of
massive infrastructure piece have ended
up on a blacklist and it just knocked
out kind of thirty percent of their
business process because they
inadvertently block something from a
threat intelligence standpoint without
actually properly betting it first right
so being able to do that type of
analytics as that data comes in rank
order it combine it together understand
what a low-quality feed is telling you
versus a high-quality fee what the
confidence difference is how to make
those decisions and how to automate all
that is something that's that's one for
sophisticated clients very important now
but as the kind of next year year and a
half two years goes by as as more threat
intelligence comes out especially in the
u.s. around some the laws that have just
been released is going to be absolutely
vital right the other side of that too
is information sharing so how does that
get linked with companies together right
so if you have a set of indicators that
you have gotten off your network because
you're seeing some campaign that no one
else is seeing how do you make sure that
efficiently moves across the wire to you
know all of your partners to folks that
you have information sharing agreements
with and how do you make sure that that
doesn't somehow have a knock-on effect
to where you you adversely disrupt the
business of a partner
right when you start kind of unpeeling
what these these threat intelligence
concepts actually mean you start to see
what the challenge is from an analytic
standpoint are really starting to
present right so it's not just about
having pictures of the building these
guys work in which is you know kind of
academically interesting but it's really
about all right how do I use this
information to best protect my estate my
business partner is a state and and kind
of the the ecosystem writ large so talk
a little bit about our what we actually
do with our threat intelligence fusion
center this this was born out of our
internal practitioners wanting to share
data more effectively right and so we we
had to build a platform that would allow
them to very easily seamlessly and
frictionless ly upload these PDF reports
Word documents txt files emails whatever
it may be drag and drop them in extract
out all the indicators and then actually
operationalize that data right so
there's a massive amount of work that
went into figuring out how to when you
drag and drop a PDF in how to rip out
kind of all the technical data in that
report and then create a workflow around
that so you have second and third level
reviewers actually saying yes this is
what we think it is yes we're assigning
this confidence to it yes we think it's
this malicious etc etc etc right because
when you start getting it at the scales
that we operate at just internally and
then also our clients operate at
ninety-five percent accuracy is not good
enough because that that can mean you
know massive amounts of massive amounts
of false positives and mass amounts of
hits right so there is still roll
there's still very much so a role for
kind of this process wrapped around the
technology being able to integrate with
third-party solutions that actually
allow us to go out and interrogate the
infrastructure right so hooking into a
solution you know such as a taenia more
those one of these endpoints solutions
is absolutely critical because those are
those
tools that are going to have the
visibility at the endpoints to be able
to push and pull this data and actually
allow us to pivot very very quickly you
know we when we look at kind of the life
of a sock analyst a security operations
center analyst in kind of the sock one
point o architecture which exists today
they spend hours switching between tools
switching between technologies switching
between online offline stuff going out
investigating things trying to pull all
this data together typically they jump
into some kind of Excel spreadsheet they
create some kind of timeline it's not
uncommon for these socks they have one
guy whose entire job it is to maintain
some kind of spreadsheet of metrics
right if you take that and actually move
to kind of this this integrated
architecture concept where all the
threat intelligence is married to all
the endpoint technologies which has a
massive analytics backbone behind it
that actually allows you to overlay the
business risk on top of that and see it
all is kind of one pane of glass as part
of the native alert you know what we're
seeing in terms of operational
efficiency is just absolutely massive
right so they're going from hours you
know today's to investigate an incident
down to you know half hour 15 minutes
eight minutes in some cases right and so
there's a lot to be said for doing this
work upfront and actually setting these
setting this single pane of glass up and
actually pulling all the data in one
place you know we we went just on the
forensic side in the IR side by doing
that you know our average time to
investigate a system went from about 3
to 4 days down to an hour hour and a
half right and that's doing kind of the
full forensic analysis because we
automated on the back end we
parallelized on the back end all the
extraction of that data out and we
automated what we could and we left the
art to the analysts to be able to
construct what they needed to construct
and we're gonna you know it's it's it's
my personal opinion we're going to see
these kind of optimizations all over the
place and so we talked about machine
learning those type things those things
are very interesting but just being able
to get the data in one place and have
all the data present for analysis is
actually going to be key
huge in getting efficiencies out of it
so and talk a little bit about what a
proof of concept looks like for us these
data numbers are a little small compared
to what we're actually doing now on
proof of concepts you know if you look
at what we're doing currently we're
actually we actually have a proof of
concept where we're taking about six
terabytes of data a day we're
maintaining that thirty millisecond
processing times that's everything from
ETL all the way through to analytics
threat intelligence look up etc instead
of two million queries which is still a
great number I'll talk about that in a
second we're actually seeing about 45 50
million queries being run against that
data right so the more you get the data
the more you making accessible the
easier to make it to query ironically
we're finding people query it more which
is great so let's talk a little bit
about this this this proof of concept so
we started out with I think there's 32
use cases that we're going to be
completely custom built for the client
right we started taking in data we took
data from about I think was 400
different log types we took in is just
kind of a massive stream we had them the
mirror off their existing log
infrastructure within about 36 48 hours
most of that was with had to end up
having to be a bit custom parsing 30 36
48 hours we had everything we had ninety
six percent of the data parsed out I
think in the next week we had something
on the area of 99.5 percent of our style
knowing we got the last five point five
percent when we when we needed it right
so being able to have that kind of
agility and being able to scale up just
transparently what you're doing just on
the parsing side and actually make that
data usable that quickly was massive
because we started receiving data on a
Thursday and then the following Friday
we were down there with 15 custom use
cases fully executed through right and
showing them stuff that none of their
other security tools other security
platforms had been able to show them and
a lot of that goes back to how quickly
we were able to spin up the Google
infrastructure how we were able to use
those tools
how we were able to not have to focus so
much on absolute efficiency of the code
but actually just getting it to work and
then able to cut to to make it more
efficient on the back end as we could
scale it down right really interesting
story kind of about this the two million
queries run 1 million of those were run
within a 24-hour period that kind of a
spike on a lot of kind of on-prem
platforms where they just have a couple
servers running in there in there
running would have absolutely tipped the
platform over right we just crashed it
the only notice we had that something
was a little bit up was we got a an
email saying hey can you check the
connectivity it looks like the platform
may be running a little bit slow and
actually what it happened is we we kind
of hit the limits on the on the scaling
we up the limits and within I think two
hours no downtime know anything else the
entire platform was back up to normal
another really interesting thing that we
found out about this we actually found
out after the fact I didn't even know
this until the sea so told somebody else
about it they decided to do a stress
test on the infrastructure and find out
if they could crash our infrastructure
because they wanted to see what our
limits work and so they went ahead and
they just without telling us they
tripled the amount of data coming in and
we didn't even notice right and every
all the all the speeds everything else
kind of scaled up it all kept running no
problems right being able to do that
because of you know what Google's put
together in their infrastructure and
what we're doing on these kind of cloud
native technologies you try that with a
nominate they did try it with an on prem
technology and it crashed and fell over
and took them and took the other you
know the other group a couple days to
actually get back to operational form
right and this you know this this story
occurs not just at small scale but large
scale which is great so when we actually
look at what we're doing here every
piece of threat intelligence that sits
in our threat intelligence portal the
threat intelligence fusion center is
looked up in real time as that data
comes through right so for our internal
instance that's about 20
e 22 million indicators right massive
number of indicators for clients it's
generally a bit smaller number but it
gives you an idea of what you're able to
do and actually able to rank order right
and this this all results in being able
to take in multiple dimensions so you
can you can you can look at threat
intelligence if you have a hit you can
marry it to what what's actually on the
system so what the business risk of it
doesn't contain third-party data are
there certain vulnerabilities that we
know about that around the system does
it play a very important role in certain
types of business processes and how does
all that link together right and being
able to use that to rank order the
criticality the alert so that you can
start pushing down some of the the noise
alerts and actually using some kind of
interesting stuff to fully marry those
out and then really raising to the top
the ones that are going to impact the
business and very very critical ways
right and so just the punch line on this
proof-of-concept is we did you know we
were side by side with with another with
another company at the time and the time
it took them to I think executed five or
six custom use cases we were actually
able to execute on 38 right and it was
so much so that they actually asked us
and this is this is something in really
nearly interesting as well when you use
these types of cloud technologies where
you have this open data architecture the
fraud team found out about this and said
hey we know you're doing a bunch of
stuff in the security side but you know
you have that data sitting there can you
use that data for fraud right and within
I think a day or two we had a couple
dashboards put together showing how we
could use all the same sets of data with
a little bit of additional stuff from a
transaction standpoint financial
transaction standpoint to show how we
can now take that same data and have a
fraud fraud alerting system right and
they're looking at this now saying wait
a minute we have all these different
infrastructures in our environment that
are collecting this type of data right
and we have many different copies of
this data why don't we just have it all
in one place and then all these
different groups can use it right so
you're not we're now seeing the
applications group the infrastructure
group the security group the fraud group
some of the customer satisfaction groups
are all looking at how they can use the
same data with different cuts in
different ways and that's when you
really really start to get to very
interesting things because then you're
able to if you see something on the
customer satisfaction side somebody
calls in to a call center they're trying
to social engineer and you want to marry
that up to what's happening on a
database at the same time that becomes
very easy because all the data is just
sitting there right and you can start to
do these really really interesting kind
of data-driven analytics and i'll go
ahead and i just have a couple
screenshots here just to talk through
you know this one's what i would call
fairly basic but just to show how we're
able to put a lot of this on one pane of
glass where you have stuff coming in
from all over the place all these
different devices and then also actually
showing the type of data that resides on
these different systems right and being
able to link all this up just as just
part of the native platform and
something our clients have found to be
enormously useful anomaly detection you
know we have an omelet diction just to
show to walk through this is a very
basic example of how we would do this
with firewall data we're actually able
to use with user data we have a
portfolio of five different algorithms
that we use for different things
depending on what the the situation is
and we can you know we can run anomaly
detection come on your basic stuff but
then actually when you start to get the
user activity data activity all those
types of things where you start to get
some really really interesting use cases
on the anomaly detection and this is
really all about driving to the unknown
unknowns that you may not know about
right and I don't know if how many of
you have worked with anomaly detection
before but it's really it can be very
messy to deal with because when an
anomaly fires there's generally very
little context about why that an anomaly
fired other than to say this is what we
were looking at and this we found an
anomaly right so being able to have all
this data in one pane of glass to where
you can drill in very quickly to all the
data around the anomaly and understand
what was happening both with the the the
you know event itself but also at the
baseline understanding how it typically
looks is something really really
critical I've talked about this already
a bit but threat if full threat Intel
integration this was something very
important to us so it's not about having
you know two separate systems one that
manages threat intelligence and then one
that manages the lookups against the
threat intelligence but actually having
all that connected together and being
able to act on that data in some kind of
algorithmic way really really critical
because we see time and time and time
again from a process standpoint when an
organization has those two systems
disconnected threat intelligence get
missed because they they invariably for
some reason will not move that over it
moves over in batches the other side of
that too is when you introduce new
threat intelligence into the ecosystem
so you have you know some new report
that just came out from ics-cert or
whatever maybe being able to do that
retro retrospectively and say
automatically every 24 hours go back and
search my logs for all these indicators
and tell me if I have an issue right and
then have a report sent out nightly on
that it's something really critical as
well in this second screen shot you'll
see down here you see kind of the
beginnings of what looked like a network
graph the other thing that we see is
being really really important is being
able to actually keep all this in one
related structure right because you will
start to see kind of these emergent
patterns pop out when you do it that way
if you're using some of these smaller
scale graph tools which are phenomenal
tools in their own right and you and you
kind of have these different versions of
each threat group or different versions
of what's happening you are going to
miss connections between threat groups
between tools usage between
infrastructure so and they make this
concrete you know we see time and time
again where an individual has defected
from one threat group to another
especially in some of the cyber crime
groups and all sudden this new siren the
cyber crime group picks up a whole new
range of tactics that they never used
before right being able to pick that up
and actually understand what's happening
underneath the hood there and the fact
that somebody may have moved over and
also now
whenever you go up against group X you
start looking for all the toxic truth
why uses as well is enormously
beneficial to our to our clients and in
protecting kind of you know society writ
large being able to do that without all
that data sitting in one place is a very
very difficult exercise right so it's
absolutely critical to keep very very
noisy data at scale and then understand
how to kind of rank order that data up
and down so endpoint monitoring and
there's there's a kind of a massive
conversation going on the industry now
about agent versus no agent when do you
deploy an agent when you not need an
agent and it's really fascinating so
this entire dashboard was created with
no in point with actually no agent on
the servers we were actually just using
the native logs that came off the server
to do this right typically it's actually
very hard to do these types of things
because a lot of this came out of a
certain type of event log type that's
very very unstructured very difficult to
deal with very hard to parse being able
to use you know Google's platform and
actually scale it to where we can really
just hammer away and parse that stuff at
scale and not to worry about throwing
twenty nodes at it allows us to create
these this type of visibility into the
environment where we can say explicitly
on any system you know that contains
third-party data whether it be regulated
it otherwise these are the programs that
were added and removed these are the
users that did it this is the time frame
you know these are the security tools
that may have been turned off and to do
all that without without agents
especially on some of these older
systems is absolutely vital right now
having said that if they do have agents
out there we want to be able to take
full advantage of those as well and we
do have you know we've spent a lot of
time because we think it's really really
valuable to be able to do push and pull
from those agent so if if we want to
take all the data they're seeing pull
into dashboarding do the analytics but
then also we want our analysts to be
able to pivot on that data and
interrogate the endpoints themselves
right so if they see something in this
where they may they may want to do a
second level and actually pull
value that gives them a fingerprint of
one of these these programs we want them
to be able to do that without having to
leave the ecosystem and pull up yet
another pane of glass right and this is
really all about kind of joining this
stuff together lastly you know we got to
have eye candy at some level and this is
that eye candy but it does actually
demonstrate a really interesting you
know point which is we're able to as the
data comes in fully geo locate it do all
the anomaly detection do all that kind
of stuff map it onto this visual create
this really kind of interesting sock
visual that you know while it looks you
know pretty and all those types of
things can actually convey information
as well because all of a sudden if you
see this and then you see a massive
connection going to a country you know
you don't do business with that should
fire up and alert somebody should go run
run that down and so it's really all
about creating these kind of novel and
interesting ways to look at look at the
data that may have been possible with
certain types of infrastructures before
but we really want to be able to do that
across the board right and do that in a
cost-effective manner and do it a manner
that helps organizations best protect
themselves and that's really what we're
focused on when we talk about our
security analytics solutions and help
how we're helping our clients kind of
move through some of these problem sets
so with that I have I believe we have
finished with kind of two minutes to
spare so I want to say thank you
everyone for listening the presentation
day if you have any questions you know
we'll be around up here after the talk
otherwise thank you for hanging up for
the last slot and have a great one
you